on va essayer de détecter les mensonges
et les chroniqueurs aussi vous allez
passer au lavage c'est le détecteur de
mensonges sur la fidélité on va avoir
des chiffres
attention c'est parti crestcom 53% des
français vous dit ne jamais avoir été
infidèle on l'a vu non non non on va
voir si ça marche
voilà merci recteur de montceau de voir
si sévère ah oui mais s'ils pouvaient se
magner plus merci donc voilà c'est bon
tu vois est-ce que ça m'a français sur
dix tu accepterais que ton conjoint
aille voir ailleurs si vous pouviez le
faire aussi non non
as tu t'es tu es jaloux tu peux pas vous
et non mais là bas sinon je m'en mets
d'ailleurs dès la fin la fois si je peux
les voir ailleurs et la guerre des
consoles est ce que comme un français
sur trois vous seriez prêt à pardonner
une infidélité si votre conjoint à
seulement embrasser une autre personne
tu peux le répéter la question est-ce
que tu serais prêt comme un français sur
trois à pardonner une infidélité si
votre conjoint à seulement embrasser une
autre et personnes oui oui c'est dur en
affaires mais lyme est ce que comme 80%
des français vous pensez qu envoyer des
sextos s'est trompé oui à droite et à la
[Musique]
scala on va chez soi ce sont des
calquières dans ce cas là je deviens
papy brossard et je suis des gâteaux
c'est vrai mais ça veut dire vous le
faites si rayonnant il prend de la
hauteur
les mecs les mecs arrêtez vous ramènerez
délicate car on veut savoir doit être au
fait de gershwin s'extrait web reviens
pas si je pose des questions j'avais en
charge de questions posées oui est-ce
que vous avez déjà envoyé un texto micro
mais quand quelqu'un vient après semaine
est-ce que j'ai dû envoyer un sex-toy
car dernière non à cette folle non bien
sûr non est-ce que vous avez des gens
n'est pas la bonne question
la vérité c'est pas la bonne question
c'est ouf alors est-ce que vous avez
déjà envoyé un texto à une femme pendant
que vous étiez en couple avec une autre
femme voilà c'est ça la question
non monsieur je tends du mans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
machine marc schneeberger aide
êtes vous un fidèle au nom du seigneur
et la vérité de ses bons à casser la
machine voilà moi alors un mur ou deux
mois avez vous déjà payé pour du sexe
ans c'est vrai j'avais jamais une fois
non c'est la seule réponse
m
[Applaudissements]
vous at on déjà payé pour avoir du sexe
non non est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
cette fois la vache et c'est parce que
vous avez vous déjà eu plusieurs
relations en même temps c'est à dire non
oui je peux pas t'en avais tu vois un
moment je me suis devrait faire du
cinoche mais sa volée dans le jeu voilà
la magie mentale en herbe sexuelle jeux
wii avec quelqu'un avec qui vous avez
travaillé
oh la vache non sur il a un moment faut
rester sérieux tu peux pas dire
n'importe quoi ce n'est pas l'accord de
moins bien comme ça se voit elie
lellouche
oui voilà la dernière fois que vous avez
rencontré l'amour c'était sur le
tournage de camping 3 ou de chacun sa
vie et y répond par oui alors camping 3
non ac c'est l'autre nom d'alors
mais a rencontré sur le tournage de top
gear un top de sa maman maman de ma
petite fille dylan mais juste un bout
que tu vas mettre des froides en tout
c'est vrai il va mettre des froids dire
merci à philippe les dernières retouches
oui mathieu de leurs yeux dans les yeux
avez vous déjà eu une curiosité dans
l'autre côté de la rivière
euh non mathieu attendez jamais attendez
attendez attendez nom a produit non non
mais attends je vais faire comme si
[Applaudissements]